- The fact that there
is thousands, you know,
hundreds of thousands, millions of people,
that watched that video,
I think that's,
- Yeah.
- That's really powerful,
so how do you think the idea
of putting lectures online would really,
MIT OpenCourse, where it has innovated?
- That was a wonderful idea!
You know, I think the
story that I've heard
is the committee was
appointed by the president,
President Vest at that
time, a wonderful guy,
and the idea of the
committee was to figure out
how MIT could make, be
like other universities,
market the work we were doing.
And, then they didn't see
a way, and after a weekend
and they had an inspiration,
and came back to President Vest, and said,
"What if we just gave it away?"
And, he decided that was okay, good idea.
- You know, that's a crazy idea.
If we think of a university as a thing
that creates a product.
- [Male In Blue Shirt] Yes.
- Isn't knowledge--
- [Male In Blue Shirt] Right.
- You know, the kind of
educational knowledge
isn't the product and giving that away.
Are you surprised that (chuckling)
it went through?
- That it went through?
The result, that he did it?
Well, knowing a little
bit, President Vest,
it was like him, I think.
And, it was really the
right idea, you know?
MIT is that kind of, it's known
for being high-level, technical things
and this is the best way we
can say, tell, we can show
what MIT really is like
'cause the, in my case,
those 1806 videos are
just teaching the class.
They were there in 26, 100.
Be kind of fun to look at,
people write to me and say,
"Oh, you've got a sense of humor,"
but I don't know where that comes through.
Just somehow, friendly with the class.
I like students and linear algebra,
we gotta give the subject
most of the credit.
It really has come forward
in importance in these years.